NOW IT'S TIME FOR
"NEW NETFLIX CATEGORIES."
WE NEED THEM.
(APPLAUSE)
I'M SURE YOU GUYS, AS YOU ARE
NETFLIXING, HAVE NOTICED THAT
THERE ARE BIZARRELY SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES, LIKE DARK CANADIAN
THRILLERS OR VISUALLY STRIKING
FATHER-SON MOVIES.
SO COMEDIANS, IN 60 SECONDS,
I WANT TO YOU BUZZ IN WITH AS
MANY NEW CATEGORIES AS YOU CAN.
FOR EACH ONE THAT MAKES US
LAUGH, 250 POINTS!
READY, SET, GO!
RIKI LINDHOME.
>> SUNDANCE MOVIES ABOUT AIDS.
>> Chris: THAT MIGHT ALREADY BE
ONE, BUT I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS.
JONAH RAY.
>> MOVIES THAT DON'T HOLD UP.
>> Chris: (BLEEP), THAT WOULD
BE AN AWESOME CATEGORY.
MOST OF THEM, POINTS.
RIKI?
>> KEIRA KNIGHTLEY SOBS
IN A CORSET.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THAT'S GOT TO BE
LIKE 14 RIGHT THERE.
POINTS!
KYLE DUNNIGAN.
>> SETH ROGAN MOVIES
NOT MADE BY JUDD APATOW.
>> Chris: POINTS!
JONAH RAY.
>> GANDHI CHICK FLICKS.
>> Chris: POINTS!
RIKI.
>> WHEN JEREMY PIVEN WAS STILL
BALD.
>> Chris: POINTS!
YEAH, LIKE ANYTHING BEFORE '98.
SINGLES!
KYLE DUNNIGAN?
>> PRE-LEGAL OLSON TWINS MOVIES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WAIT, WILL YOU PLEASE
SAY THAT AS CRAIG?
>> PRE-LEGAL OLSON TWINS MOVIES.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
JONAH RAY.
>> MUSIC DOCUMENT...
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> Chris: DO IT, DO IT!
>> MUSIC DOCUMENTARIES ABOUT
BANDS YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF
THAT NEVER MADE IT.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
RIKI?
>> MOVIES WHERE WHITE WOMEN
SOLVE RACIAL ISSUES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
JONAH.
>> MOVIES NIC CAGE MADE
BECAUSE HE'S IN DEBT.
>> Chris: YES!